I think it's fair to say it's
notoriously difficult to make a lot of
money as a robotics company
how can you make money as a robotics
company can you speak to that it seems
that a lot of Robotics companies fail
it's difficult to build robots it's
difficult to build robots at a low
enough cost where customers even the
industrial setting want to purchase them
and it's difficult to build robots that
are useful sufficiently useful so what
can you speak to and Boston Dynamics has
been
uh successful for many years of finding
a way to make money well in the early
days of course you know the money we
made was from doing contract r d work
and we made money
but you know we weren't growing and we
weren't selling a product
and then we went through several owners
who
you know had a vision of not only
developing advanced technology but
eventually developing products and so
both you know Google and SoftBank and
now Hyundai
you know had that vision and were
willing to you know provide uh that in
investment
um now our discipline is that we need to
go find applications that are broad
enough that you could imagine selling
thousands of robots because it doesn't
work if you don't sell thousands or tens
of thousands of robots if you only sell
hundreds
the com you will commercially fail and
that's where most of the small robot
companies have died
um
and and that's a challenge because
you know a you need to field the robots
they need to start to become reli
reliable and as we've as we've said that
takes time and investment to get there
and so it really does take Visionary
investment to get there but we we
believe that we are going to make money
in this uh industrial monitoring space
because
you know if uh if a chip Fab if the line
goes down because a vacuum pump failed
someplace that can be in a very
expensive process it can be a million
dollars a day in Lost production maybe
you have to throw away some of the
product along the way
and so the robot if you can prevent that
by inspecting the factory every single
day maybe every hour if you have to
there's a real return on investment
there but there needs to be a critical
mass of this task and and we're focusing
on a few
that we believe are
ubiquitous in the industrial production
environment and that's using a thermal
camera to keep things from overheating
using an acoustic imager to find
compressed air leaks using visual
cameras to read gauges
measuring vibration these are standard
things that you do to prevent unintended
shutdown of a factory
and this this takes place in a beer
factory we're working with a B inbev it
takes place in chip Fabs you know we're
working with global foundries it takes
place in Electric and Utilities and
nuclear power plants and so the same
robot
can be applied in all of these
industries
and and as I said we have about actually
it's 1100 spots out now to really get uh
you know profitability we need to be at
a thousand a year maybe maybe 1500 a
year you know for that sort of part of
the business so it still needs to grow
um but but we're on a good path so I
think that's totally achievable so the
application should require Crossing that
thousand robot barrier it really should